here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Timothy sha'lame call me by your name
[Applause]
Daniel day-lewis Phantom thread-local
Ouya get out
Kalvin darkest hour
Denzel Washington rumen J Israeli Squire
and the winner is Gary Oldman Gary
Oldman he received his first nomination
for his leading performance and Tinker
Tailor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well my my deepest thanks to the Academy
and its members for this ah this is this
glorious ripp prize I owe this and so
much more to so many I have I've lived
in America for the longest time and I am
deeply grateful to her for the loves and
the friendships I have made and the many
the many wonderful gifts it has given me
my my home my livelihood my family and
now Oscar the movies such as their their
their power captivated a young man from
South London and gave him a dream and
Douglass of Bansky my dear dear friend
and brother you have helped keep that
dream alive Joe Wright thank you for
this it only took 20 years for us to
work together but it was well worth the
wait
thank you Kazu Lucy
David for your for your artistry thank
you everyone
a working title and universal focus for
your Herculean efforts and support on
this film thank you Eric Felner Tim
Bevan Lisa Bruce Antony McCartan Danny
and her amazing team
I'm of and of course Jim Osborne I would
like to I would just like to salute Sir
Winston Churchill who has been marvelous
accompany on what can be described as an
incredible journey and my wife Giselle
for traveling that road with me and
at my side thank you Alfie gali Charlie
William my remarkable remarkable fellow
nominees and my my dear friend have
their Denzel and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna win the that you know the ski I
would like to thank my mother who was
older than the Oscar she is 99 years
young next birthday she is watching the
ceremony from the comfort of her sofa I
say to my mother thank you for your love
and support put the kettle on and bring
in Oscar